you know Josh definitely 1.13 patch came
out today huge laundry list of items a
lot of kind of just smaller changes
nothing huge or impacting a lot of like
you know aesthetic changes HUD changes
UI changes you know what are the big
ones for you I thought they did a lot of
cool things maybe people didn't
specifically ask for things like when
you enter a level now it's not going to
continuously unpause you if you're
checking out your inventory little
annoying things like that but a big one
is voice chat now with strangers you can
manually opt-in and that makes it easier
to do that with strikes and stuff and
then combined with easier scaling for
nightfall I feel like now it's time to
add matchmaking for nightfall yeah so
it's interesting that you bring that up
that they've kind of come out and said
you know night falls they're not going
to be as easy solo because I guess
everyone was soloing them in the past
also because like you said there's no
matchmaking now there's going to scale a
little bit better when you actually have
it have a team in the past where i was
like shot and get out of my nightfall or
just get have my knife all right now you
guys are making it exponentially harder
for me yeah it's over twice as much
damage for a lot of enemies so it makes
it a lot tougher but if they can pull
off matchmaking the nightfall maybe its
paving the way for matchmaking with
raids who knows yeah I mean that's the
bigger one wat see that haven't really
talked too much about that one but maybe
like he said maybe a paves the way for
that it's interesting with the voice
chat because like you can toggle it on
left or right with the directional pad
when you get in there I think I was
trying it just now for our news video
where you know like I was hitting fire
there's fire teen chat and then there's
also like the strike chat which I assume
would also be inducible but it's like
okay I turned it on like hey guys how do
you like destiny i was just like joking
around I'm like can you guys hear me no
they can't spin around in a circle you
can hear me is like nope didn't hear any
other everyone's used to not talking
through the strikes people figured out
like you just run to the end you run
through it as fast as you can at this
point it's almost too late with the
strikes you don't need to talk people
figured out how to beat it without any
communication all your materials now
they all look different like this and
the sorry the spin metal and the
boom they're like different color
healing coil the helium coils they look
totally different in addition like your
melee and your grenade the totally
different it's like a blue instead of
like a clear kind of grayish colors I
hope now you know like oh I have a
grenade oh I have melee I guess also to
like another cool thing they finally
added is evil levante she finally
decided to be like I'm going to sell
more than just these four boring shaders
I sell all the time for me first times
like oh tundra devil I'm freaking play
400 hours i still have Thunder devil
yeah and then she finally sells it and
it's like then I find it but else got
that was just like yeah yeah like that's
just how destiny is right but I mean
those kind of things are cool so she's
gonna start selling shaders that you
could only get kind of from oron Jesus
like I didn't have any other shaders
yeah I know some of you guys had like
that weird number one and thunder devil
but that's cool I feel like that had to
be one of the most requested features is
ways to get shaders because I mean once
you reach a certain point you get gear
so rarely that it's really the only way
to differentiate yourself so more
variety there is obviously a popular
request yeah i mean but now let's build
upon that and make it so that your
factions actually like you can actually
get the shader at like a certain level
because like I've been doing grinding
down orbit to like 11 now and I still
don't have any initiators that they have
the offer which is kind of like BS but
on the other hand you probably have like
35 chatter whites so it's like they need
to find the balance there yeah pretty
much a lot of the multiplayer maps
pretty much got changes in terms of like
okay there's like kind of cheaper spots
on the map that maybe someone can't see
but then they can see everyone so
they've kind of balanced some of that
and I think they also changed like one
of the control points for blind watch
we'll see how that works out but the
bigger the bigger one is the revamp of
iron banner it's coming back you can
actually wrap up to level five now and
on top of that you can get you know your
level 30 gloves and a boot so that you
can do it's like their way of saying hey
the dlc is coming out soon why don't you
get some gear for that to get the 30
faster because some people like yourself
you're having problems still doing the
raid and getting your gear I don't play
too much crucible except for when I have
to because of an exotic bounty or
something like thorn speaking of which
apparently they accidentally nerfed
thorn which is kind of like more salt in
the wound because they said they're
going to buff it so long ago and haven't
really
in that sense so i don't know if that's
coming soon there's not a lot of
communication there but that's the real
bummer if you've got thorne and you're
waiting for it to get better it's worse
yeah I mean that it's that's not the
only gun to as well that they've
mentioned that they're gonna buff or
whatnot but it's kind of scary to think
we're gonna buff your gun but then they
nerf your gun a little bit and they're
like no no we didn't mean to do that I'm
with speaking of bounties that the other
big kind of change too is that you're no
longer locked 25 bounties they've
finally unlocked 10 bounty so like if
you had three exotic bounties you
weren't screwed and like I can only pick
up to so that's another big change yeah
and it's one of those like great that's
convenient I'd love more vault space as
well if it's as easy as it is for the
bounties I'd expect to change like that
to come down the line eventually yeah
quality of life stuff definitely a lot
of quality of life stuff I guess another
fun thing is you know this this week's
about to end but the nice ball was the
Archon priest and they finally decided
hey you can't go under that platform
anymore I tested it they just instead of
you just isn't invisible like you can't
walk through it so there is still the
cliff method apparently so there's
always going to be a chief nothing I
guess yeah this thing with every boss
there it seems like there's a cheese
method they're eventually going to patch
them one by one but people will continue
to find exploits I'm sure it is also
surprising how large the patch was it
wasn't just a few kilobytes like you
need to change values they're adding a
lot of content including spaces and
stuff for the dark below so you could
assume a lot of that contents now on
your machine even though you can't get
to it until December 9th a few weeks
away I'm sure there's a lot of stuff I'm
sure Internet's gonna start blowing up
with a lot of data mined stuff of just
like people looking up what's going to
be in dark below I mean that's in three
weeks so looking forward to that I mean
I'm sure you are you want that new
content we're gonna get to do your stuff
so yeah definitely yeah
it was better off in the prison Felton
you